trois lieux historiques du japon inscrit
au patrimoine mondial de l'unesco avec
3776 mètres d'altitude le mont fuji est
le point culminant du japon ce volcan
est toujours considérée actif même si sa
dernière éruption remonte à 1707 les
volcanologues considère qu'un vol corps
est éteint s'il est resté inactif
pendant dix mille ans chaque année
environ 300000 personnes gravi le mont
fuji inscrit au patrimoine mondial de
l'unesco le 22 juin 2013 2 le mémorial
de la paix de hiroshima ou dôme de
genbaku fût le seul bâtiment à rester
debout près du lieu où explosa la
première bombe atomique le 6 août 1945
il est aujourd'hui le symbole de la
force destructrice de l'homme mais il
incarne aussi espoir de la p3 construit
au viiie siècle
le taux daiji est un temple bouddhiste
situé à nara dans le centre du japon
dans l'enceinte le bâtiment principal le
day boat soudaine mesure 57 mètres de
large et 50 de hausse et le plus grand
édifice en bois du monde